[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Nate is
with us in Austin Texas hi Nate how are
you uh what's up guys uh how you guys
doing today better than we deserve sir
how come we
help all right so I
am actually just turned uh 30 yesterday
I am happy birthday debt free oh thank
you I am debt free
um I am on baby step four five and six I
guess
um and my income is about 85 to 100,000
a year um so my question
is I'm trying to save up for a house um
but I was thinking of going a different
route uh so I want to try and save up as
much money as I can for the next
two to three to four years right and I
want to basically buy a piece of land
and put a mobile home on it and just try
to pay it off in one big chunk okay I
can save up pretty
much 75 to 80% of my income you're
single I have a girlfriend
um but you're not my point you're not
married and so you don't have to talk
her into living in a
trailer no no no okay so yeah so uh my
question
is should I try and save up as much
money as I can and try and just pay
something off
cash um if you bought a piece of land
and put an very very very very
inexpensive trailer on
it that would mean you'd have be living
rentree yeah and you could you know very
quickly then save up the money to build
a house and get rid of that trailer but
whatever you pay for that trailer is
going to be lost
money so we're not talking about $30,000
and we're not talking about $20,000
we're talking about $10,000 or
less yeah which ain't much
dude this is not a high standard of
living
here yeah correct yeah your your
girlfriend's not going to be impressed
with your
bod yeah uh so we already kind of talked
about it um she doesn't really care uh
where she lives um well she's not living
there you
are yeah
but uh don't tell her this but I'm
probably going to marry her uh in 2024
uh oh okay now we got a different part
of the equation yeah that's what I've
been naming it in this whole
conversation your secret is you just ch
us and 30 million people yeah there's
just about 30 million of us that have to
keep your secret now but anyway but the
uh uh uh let me just tell you it's a
whole different equation for you to live
in a $10,000 trailer for four years or
your wife to live there for four years
and I know what she
says but I I you know it's just a
different equation you can count on it
guys we can sleep under a bridge it
doesn't bother us not me ladies are well
I know that's true and you know we we
get accustomed to the Finer Things We Do
Ken but uh I mean I'm Motel 6 is
roughing it I'm just saying but the uh
she may change her mind halfway through
this deal I agree with you my question
is why are we why are we in a I'm not
saying it's a hurry but why is this the
scenario why isn't it why not why not
just rent an apartment and save a bunch
of money if you're going to get married
I'd rent an apartment and save a bunch
of money me too I don't get living out
on the land I would I might live out on
the land if it's me by myself just
because I love the math part of it oh I
no so yeah so I'm actually am running um
a duplex in Austin and it's um I'm
probably going to be here for the next
two to three to four years uh because my
rent is like insanely low well yeah just
stay there with her then after you're
married and just and then you don't need
the trailer but just pay cash for the
land and then save up and pay cash for
the build I'm okay with that yeah that's
not that's a no-brainer I like that
better yeah that that makes a lot more
sense but we've had over the years Nate
we've had a lot of people that are
listeners that have done the I'm going
to buy a piece of land and live I'm
going to build a barn with a bedroom in
it a barn dominium and live in the barn
while we build the house I've had people
do that I've had people buy the $10,000
trailer put it on there they do that um
but I always answer questions like what
would I do if I were in your shoes if I
woke up and I was you knowing what I
know now and what I know now is Sharon's
not living in that trailer yeah that's a
great Point not cuz she's a snob cuz
she's not and not cuz she wouldn't
follow me anywhere cuz she would cuz you
know that you know she'd do anything for
me ABS um oh my God
but yeah yeah follow me anywhere as long
as it's to the rits of the Four Seasons
but yeah but the uh
uh I'll follow you to the pool at I'll
follow you to the pool I'll follow you
to the resort you just know better I'll
follow you to the club the point is you
just know better old and we've done it
we've been there done that on the
sacrifice thing so uh but yeah but the
point is um if I were at 26 and married
uh that would not that'd be a different
equation for me to do that by myself
than I would ask my wife to do that
that's the truth now some ladies are
perfectly fine with that and some aren't
and there's nothing wrong with either
Camp uh it's not a bad it's not a moral
judgment and it's not a snobbery thing
or anything like that I'm not too good
to do that so just keep your stupid
little TR in to yourself on that but um
that's not going to do with that it's
just got to do thinking through what is
realistic what is sustainable what am I
going to be able to do for a long enough
period of time that it has the effect
yeah yeah and it's going to take a
minute that's right create your free
every dollar budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life